hello everybody hope that you are good
sorry because I know that for the last
seven or 10 days I haven't been very
active but I've been quite busy in real
life and I was busy with that and I
couldn't do much here it's also quite
difficult to keep up with my trading
also sharing some things in social media
and real life so I left a bit on the
side the social media I was still
trading not as much as I would like to
but I've take a few trades so I'm still
going on my on my path of of goals but
now I'm going to be able to to post more
content and because it's been quite a
long time since I haven't posted any
content and I didn't give you any
guidance for the last week pretty much
and I think that justifies to make a
video in this in this moment because I
can guide you through all the different
time frames explain my perspective
although it's not that important because
it's just my opinion but I know that
some of you want to know my opin
so I think a video is the best way um
I'm going to start with the weekly time
frame which is the the highest time
frame that I use I really go on the
monthly I usually stay on the weekly and
the first thing that I want to say is
that the last video I posted was 3
months ago was the 2nd of August and I
remember we were here we were exactly at
62k right in here and I was telling you
guys what a 62k but you know what it's
not the time to buy yet because I think
we're going to go to the weekly 50ma now
only two or 3 days after price spack
down to the weekly 50ma that's the level
and it created a long week I also called
for that uh 50% of the week getting
filled it happened we tested it again
the quickly 50ma and support is is
working as a very strong support I would
say that that's our main support in in
high time in the high time frame um as
also said on Twitter several times as
long as price keeps above the weekly
50ma what in a bull market the weekly
50ma it can be a good sign to determine
whether we are in a bare or bull market
uh you can go back back and check what
happens but yeah pretty much every time
the price stays above the weekly 50ma
what market for example look at this
what happened here look at all of the
all of the price action look at all
these weeks to the downside there
holding above the weekly 50a okay then
eventually here you have a little
deviation price goes above it retrace
continuation okay and here the opposite
happened drop retrace to test the weekly
50 Ms resistance and that is telling you
here especially with this retest here
that we're entering a better Market
because the weekly 50a is acting as
resistance okay
um same as here you go back up
retrace you are holding it you push
again again continuation all right so as
long as we stay above the weekly 50a in
the weekly time frame of course then we
are we are fine we can continue going up
that's what I think so um am I running
any swing shorts no why would I if I
believe that as long as we're above the
weekly 50a there is a big chance of
price continue going higher all right
now the next thing is that if we go into
the daily time
frame uh you can throw this as a range
but um I prefer in this case to to keep
it as a channel but again I might defer
with some of your opinions but this is
to me the way that I'm playing this and
here I want to pay attention because
this is quite key to me um this what I
notice okay okay I think we're going to
break out of this pattern and we're
going to see higher prices and I'm going
to explain to you that this is a channel
so if we
draw a channel here
okay sorry I'm I'm using the the
touchpad and I'm quite slow with it but
basically this is what you see in a
channel okay price is doing this and
price doesn't do this that's not how a
channel works okay channels in my
opinion and in my experience what they
usually do is this they do all of this
stuff that we've seen and then in the
moment that it wants to break up from
this area it goes to the 50% of the
channel and then it can go up sometimes
you can see that retrace
here and that's when we work but the key
to me is this that in my
experience we usually see the retrace
quite shallow to the middle of the of
the channel and all the way to the
bottom again all right so that to me is
quite important and I'm going to explain
to you why that is important to
me and it's simply because if you notice
here guys hang on I think I how I dra
something like this if you notice this
and I
get that
there you want to
notice
how this exactly the
50% between the range well between the
the top part of the channel and the
bottom part of the channel the 50% is
exactly that level where we set a week
and then we saw a good bounce so that is
telling me that is happening okay that
is telling me that this is a very
very likely breakout of this structure
cuz you go up then you go to the 50%
exactly and that is your breakout now
from here we might get a retrace back to
back to the back to the top part of the
channel or we might not get it that's
optional and from there we can continue
going up all right now also another
thing that's quite interesting of this
structure is that if you mark the
highest that 7
3,777 quite a strange number okay but
then you can mark for example this
strong
resistance over here okay so iag that
most of you will agree that that orange
line there it's quite strong
resistance but if you notice guys look
at this okay we set the
high fine but then you have a week here
another week here one more touch here
another one there and this area here
between the orange line and the jellow
line that is full of liquidity this area
here that is full of liquidity we have
to run those Highs at some point and
yeah I'm telling you that if this is
between
72,73
777 price needs to go and fill this area
sooner or later so yes I'm favoring
higher prices and higher time frame
because the structure that that we've
been talking about that channel that
this looks like a breakout and also
because we have these highs here that we
have to run at some
point right so if you put those two
things together it's very likely that
that's going to happen next all right
now more things that I want to
mention I have a few things to mention
to be honest is on the 4 hours time
frame that is something that I don't
really like much and I'll tell you what
it is first of all the 4our 50a is very
very extended look at that we haven't
really touched it since the 30th of
October and there is a price
difference quite high of around
5% and with been five days without going
to it and
really in this moment we could have
dropped it's true we could have dropped
to the 450 m but price is still showing
some some strength um we're going to go
back now in a minute to h capital to see
if there is any liquidity in this area
the spoiler that is but I want to show
you that also but my point is that at
some point Bitcoin needs to retrace back
to the 4H hour 50a now if Bitcoin
continues running higher and
consolidates here and then it starts to
drop by then it's possible that the 4 or
8 creeps all the way
to this potential Support over here okay
that would be the best case because
maybe then your St is here a
range and you do a bit of consolidation
here maybe you ruin the lows back off
maybe a little drop again and continue
going up but uh right now what I want to
see is that if I'm going to take a day
trade it would be looking for a short
scalp in a as a day trader to the four
or 50 may but the problem is where can I
short that from and that's also what I'm
going to try to go through in this video
but again that's just my opinion and
again as a as a day trader or a scalper
no well not not really a scalper more as
a day trader but not as a swing Trader
because
overall the the trend is to the upsite
all right so um yeah that's the main
thing in the four time frame now if you
don't mind let's have a quick look at
high Capital let's look at the
liquidation hit map so we're in h
capital and we're in the one month time
frame and if you take this area here
you're going to notice how yes very is
quad of liquidity all the way to
69,3 but especially the the hot places
the hot levels are 68,800
and the spe eally 69,00 all the way to
69300 so that's the level I'm taking
okay
69.3 now if you go into the 7 Days time
frame which is a lower time frame we're
going to see a few more interesting
liquidation levels so let's take all of
this area
here and again you can notice here
69,3 so yeah that is this a liquidation
cluster that if you notice we're already
entering here because the liquidation
cluster would have gone between 68,500
to
69300 and we're already halfway we are
eating up all those liquidation points
but again it's not finished the job is
not finished until we get to
693 so could 693k be a level a potential
level
for a short again for day Traders back
to the 4H hour 50 and then the question
is if we see that drop to the 450 M and
it holds a support could that be a good
position a good place to position
yourselves in some altcoins if if you
haven't
already and again let's take the 7 Days
time frame because I think there was a
level to the downside that I didn't pay
much attention to so let's have a look
it's quite far still it's um 64,500 but
is too far and this will change this
changes every seven days and it'll
probably Fade Into the one month time
frame not so with that much
liquidity but that's not a level I'm
interested yet because I think that is
going to be below the 4 or 50 May so it
doesn't really matter does it and then
in the liquidation levels
which I haven't checked today
yet um I'm going to change it to the max
liquidity
setting let's have a look okay we have
how
much
24.5 billion dollar worth of long
liquidations again take this amount with
a pins of sold it's not real I'm using
the max liquidity setting it's just a
calculation formula a method um to guess
how heavily the market is in One
Direction and according to this usually
when we see the Delta between
25 and 30 billions that is telling you
that price is likely going to reverse
and when it's between 30 and
35 usually in my experience I telling me
the reversal is about to happen now it
doesn't need to go all the way there it
can reverse from here okay but my point
is that if we see this increasing to
around around 30
billions which is only five from here
then price is very likely to reverse
from the exact point and if we start to
see now price spiking
up strongly to 69 to 3K at the same time
as the Delta increases to around $30
billion that is telling you that this
could be a Confluence to see a reversal
in price all right so there a few things
that you can um keep an eye on if you
are using this this tool of high capital
and it's something that I want to be
paying attention to and that is
something that I wanted to mention now
let's go back to the
Chart so yeah um price action wise um 1
hour time frame you can see occasional
retraces to the 1 hour 50 May and then
bounces you can see here but you can
also see here and that is something that
I would like to see in the 40 time frame
why not why can I do something like
this for example all right give me that
touch St or at least a consolidation at
the 4H hour 50 MAA again I'm not going
to tell you the Target because it's a
dynamic Target it's a EMA it's delayed
so it's going to continue keeping
upwards but because a lot of Market
participants use this indicator this
metric
then I think it's quite important to
keep an eye on you can see here for
example push up retrace continuation now
my validation for this idea it's quite
simple I do think that if price
loses or drops below this area here
64,000 then that's going to be
quite um I mean still you have the way
daily 50 May is not ideal because you
would be falling you would be breaking
this structure here which is a
potential W view pattern here okay you
have that the retrace
continuation retrace continuation so if
price drops below this orange line then
it invalidates this next leg up all
right that's um also something that I
wanted to mention
um yep overall I think that's everything
that I want to say in this video um what
else the Bitcoin dominance
59% Benjamin Benjamin
Cohen you must be a very happy man right
now I don't know I I thought you're
watching this or that this will get to
you but uh congrats uh cuz I've been
seeing you calling this for I think
couple of years right now it's been two
years I think and he's always said the
Bitcoin dominance is going to get to
60% and come on we're so close to it um
it's not something beish and dominance
is a topic that I really like and it's
just something Bish and Benjamin
mentioned 60% and I liked his opinion
and I also ched this by myself and I
thought that what he said he make a lot
of sense and I been also supporting that
theory or for quite long time and my
point is that guys if you notice here
look at the Bitcoin dominance okay this
was some kind of resistance there that
then it Go flipped into support
continuation
fine we have been in a Range here for
two years look at this since May
2021 to May 2023 two years of a range
during this time with the seasons
because this drop for example here
that's just an Al rally nothing else
same as here all right and during this L
up here Al coins are holding pretty well
simply because Bitcoin has been going up
nonstop so Alin Haven super that much
and that we can be a bit dramatic here
and it seems that it's worse than it is
in my opinion but alons have held pretty
well and we're seeing some new Alon like
sui or I don't know there are many Al
that have been doing really well but my
point is
if you want to Alison then we needed
this okay we needed the Bitcoin
dominance to have a rally because the
moment that it reverses and I do think
that it's going to get back to the back
to the range highs I don't think we're
going to end up back inside this range
but I do think we're going to test the
range highs and that's a big drop if you
notice of already H 12% now withing that
drop there that is your SE guys
if we see the drop which I believe we
will that is your All
Season again as long as Bitcoin doesn't
drop because if Bitcoin drops at the
same time as the Bitcoin dominance drops
then the whole Market is going to drop
it doesn't matter that there is an all
season it's going to be eclipsed by
Bitcoin falling okay so you're not going
to get what you want but H if you see
the Bitcoin dominance dropping from 60%
or 61% and you see dropping all the way
to the range highs which I think it
happen we only need Bitcoin to either go
up like it's been doing now or just
consolidate if Bitcoin consolidates and
the Bitcoin dominance drops what still
going to see um altcoins outperforming
Bitcoin and doing really well so do I
want to be positioned in alss of course
yes of course yes no doubt and I don't I
do think that the time um could be soon
to be honest I think the time could be
soon and that's why if you are not
positioning in Al then consider doing so
because I haven't been position for
quite a few months and in the last month
two months three months that's when I've
been started buying okay since I posted
my last video of I'm buying a 53,000 and
I told you some price levels where I was
buying a lot of coins like um fetch AI
that we bought it at 0.82 now it's at
150 * two pretty much uh well there's a
lot of coins that I'm not going to go
through all of them maybe I do a new
altcoin video soon but my point is that
if you haven't positioned yourself on
bitcoin F to to
53k what probably and this is my opinion
we're not going to see this prices again
I think there is a high chance that
Bitcoin continues going up but for that
we have to take advantages of these
drops okay giveing up to the 450
the Bitcoin dominance is rising then
Bitcoin drops what's going to happen to
altcoins they're going to drop a lot if
Bitcoin drops here altcoins drop here
and that is going to give you a good dep
to buy into some alcons right and I
don't want to go much into it but think
upos the chart of s what do you think
this coin is going to
do if Bitcoin loses the 4our 50ma look
at it yes it keeps going up but come on
it's always so close to drop okay so
what happens now if Bitcoin goes a bit
up and then it drops to the 450 man well
this coin for example is going to drop
even more it might drop all the way here
to 160 okay that is telling
you a
potential 20% drop I mean why not it's
happened before guys look at this this
and this is pretty similar you also have
the daily 50ma catching up I don't know
uh these are the type of setups that I'm
looking at um as a day trader looking to
short Bitcoin once it gets to a level
and a liquidation Delta that I'm think
that the chances are quite High to drop
I haven't been short in all this time so
um you cannot say well you've been
shorting all the way up no haven't I've
been long all the way up but now it's
true that I see a a lik likelihood for
Bitcoin to reverse soon okay so as a day
trader yeah I may be looking for Bitcoin
to drop and take advantage of the short
but as a spot Trader or a swing Trader
I'm looking forward that drop to add
onto some um swing Longs or spot
positions into some alins because I do
think that Bitcoin dominance is one a
top option
okay so yeah I think that's a good
moment to wrap this
up again I want to apologize for not for
not have been active on X and on telam
lately and thank you everybody that have
joined my well my with my blin referral
link that new exchange um I'm going to
give you all access to the indicator but
we are still setting up the board CU
I've been quite busy so by the end of
the month it'll be ready
I promise you and you will you will all
will have access to my indicator that if
we go very quickly to bitcoin we can see
functioning now can for example go to
the for time frame or The Works in time
frames and then you can start playing
with it for example give me the week
fill strategy any wiels that have not
been filled let me
see guess that's a no let's continue you
can Mark liquidity pools you can change
the 50 Ma
to the time frame you want although in
the second version we want add a second
50 MAA so you can have one running for
example in the 4our time frame and or
another one in in a different time frame
and liquidity pools look at this guys
this liquidity pull to the downside is
very far away but to the upside look at
these two liquidity pools and this is
the area that I'm telling you that there
is liquidity because the highs haven't
been hit yet okay we have to Ru to High
still so yes there is qu of liquidity
there um yeah that's pretty much
everything guys uh thank you so much for
watching I hope that the video was quite
useful and I'll see you soon